che cosa ma quanto scritto ad avere è
cascato un coso che è meglio che non
sappiate che cos'è venti ragazze nude
questo è un video sono valigie è uscita
la demo tutta questo caso è uscita la
demo di residenti volo quello che avevo
già provato solo che è uscita la prima
ora di gioco in teoria non credo di aver
capito così poi magari non è vero allora
gli anni riuscire a fare una roba
decente acquista è borrelli abbia gioco
non regna di che pur che trovi e
bellissimo trova una via d'uscita mica
subito non c'è filmato niente bellissimo
ti serve una videocassetta sia come come
la democratica fatto che troviamo st
videocassetta grido di pianoforte
[ __ ] ma stanza di tua madre cazzo è
sempre pianoforte di mortacci poter
beethoven
manca una possibile guarda ti manca
anche al cervello il fusibile dunque
tutto bene avanti
ragazzi io aggiungo la roba non mi
ricordo una sega di quello che ho
giocato ok perché l'avevo già fatto che
i miei amici sta demo però non me la
ricordo 1 e secondo l'avevo fatta colpo
aree quindi è difficile che mi sbatte la
porta di sbatto la madre
basta con l'uso cagato uguale
ecco qui soltanto di qua mi conoscono fa
ragazzi john l'alzheimer non mi ricordo
niente permesso ciao ci sono falli j
sono tutti ho pagato io allora non mi
ricordo cosa ho giocato ma di sicuro sta
porta non si era aperta in prima volta
quindi fantastico permesso porca vacca
la lega che si tipo munizioni pistola
veramente non ce l'ho io ho la pistola
ma che ti chiamerò regga il gioco più 22
st giornalisti una passo d'addio maistra
andare in bagno quando la tua tipo alle
sue cose in questo caso potrebbe essere
una tragedia sembra che poi a staccarci
qualcosa la stacca di arca c'è una
bicicletta nella nostra romagna ok
ragazzi vi sto pagando in mano
non so se mi interessa è la madonna non
c'è acqua nel serbatoio non la guarda
non credo che servisse a qualcosa
munizioni visto io troppo punizione
pistola se non trovo una pistola giuro
che vi uccido la la madre chiaramente
non potete mettervi le munizioni a
pistola e non mettervi la pistola mi
girano poi attivi quaderno moto a
quattro mani la tematica
quando prendo appunti su inizio di
pistola aridaje questo momento di
pistola non so a pistola credo insomma
ma ho una porta allegra finalmente
questa roba
no no non la vicina da vicino perché
senza che sfruttano la cosa vado via e
chiude a non è commosso niente per
strano in teoria doveva comparire
qualcosa
conosco troppo bene gli horror da semi
dato la pistola che sono sempre contento
è una che mi dava figlia quindi qua non
c'è nulla torniamo allora prima perfetto
io ragazzi
ricordavo che quale ha ragione
eccola sarebbe praticamente ragazzi la
porta dove poi si è questo un fusibile
ma non avevo messo l'altra volta chiusa
la non equa non esso sono forte ho messo
così via adesso lo so ho fatto mi dai
mi dai dolci cosa servito su così via
scusante ma basta sto perdendo mai è
chiaro chi c'è babbo natale di sopra non
è ancora nata l'estate la casa non va
questa
la vita è una merda e se non vi
controllate il culo fate schifo però
ragazzi miei bene ma si può provare con
un'altra volta non sono andato con sopra
sono scemo io el'altro finale perché ci
sono due pro chiama volete che ci sono
due finali sto gioco però non erano ok
allora questa è l'altra parte non sono
mai stato quando nei dati che cosa ci
sia non è lo stesso gioco con il quale
diverso proprio ci hanno aggiunto delle
rose c'è una nostra vita sta roba
permesso michele bello è sta roba qua
qua non ci sono mai stato salve signor
non ci sono mai stato quindi non ho idea
di che cosa succede dopo non ce l'ho
neanche minimamente posso fare la
chiamata la telefonata a casa di paul
milionario una pizza grazie mia testa
fratelli una domanda ci stanno i vostri
amici va dietro se volete raggiungerli
va bene
già che ci siamo beh cazzo c'è una sala
o non inglobate v mentre salgo la scala
casi di sale ok
ma è chiusa è chiusa sembra che porti
fuori mappa sherlock holmes può farti
sono una p fazio complimenti
niente allora andiamo di qua facciamo di
qua c'è un'altra porta che gioia e che
uguaglia sono contento che sia chiusa va
bene così vorrei chiave seminterrato
sono contentissimo ragazzi possono fare
il seminterrato alla lunga devo l'ora da
stamattina che ci voglio andare
sono contento sono permesso sul latte di
londra nel seminterrato mi dispiace
permesso ma è quello seminterrato giusto
o state calmi state lo stesso border e
locali permesso è che avesse ritorna a
giocare cazzo come sono contento sii
bene era proprio il posto che volevo
raggiungere viva la vita
porque no vabbè veramente ragazzi vide
testo vide testo lo giuro cos'è sta
merda permesso
sono famiglie sono successo perché ho
trovato una chiave o delle munizioni
vede regalo se state tranquilli ben
chiaro in testa che cazzo as rumore
per me buongiorno
dalle col dio ci sono dei cadaveri forza
s'è chiusa la porta seduta si è chiusa
poi è caduto ficcare in calce al
cadavere che cosa ma quando stai ad
avere cosa cazzo era già indemoniato uno
scaffale con tasti e volate uno scaffale
non so dov'è il joystick lo penso ho
perso joystick aggiunto ecco come è
finito qua dietro il joystick e volato
uno scaffale bene
fallo
rosso a quella forza che le situazioni
di meno dai più dai pastai ai ragazzi ma
anche una porta ma veramente
ma cos'è allora fatemi capire come la
battaglia tra tizia come faccio a
batterla allora qua c'è questa roba
quasi una nota la valvola motor negli
harem e la fonte torriglia club [ __ ]
noto il frate frate puoi capire con la
cazzo di porta cosa di costa ma per che
cosa ho trovato così trovando non ha
capito cosa ho trovato con visto chiave
finestra antico la finestra dell'artico
come come ci arrivo nella finestra
dell'attico togliti era bloccato tutta
la [ __ ] come ci arrivo io nella
finestrella chiuso sfonda nicchia osso
vivo è vivo non ci posso credere non ci
credo ce l'ho fatta vai vai vai da
profeta per micio la mano la cerchi la
porta chi l'ha posta chiudi la porta
chiusa volta la valvola a terra ma non
so che cosa serva ma va bene
destino madonna la mia vita è completa
ma che sa bene ai prezioso voglia di
scherzare ancora con le porte chiuse ma
tu che hai chiuso la porta prima 26
vieni qua
dai che giochiamo più di un attimo tutta
vanto sei proiettili ciò sai proietti in
croce faccio veramente schifo vai vai
vai
[Musica]
vabbè l'accesso la mano vabbè lasciamo
perdere mai la rai manderà piano di
sopra piani sopra portarci le tua madre
è tanto se la pistola divieti contro
ieri è passato qualcuno di quale mentre
che non c'è non sa perché una pistola in
fila grazie
macché ma cos'è e non c'è nessuno vai
vai vai apri apri apri dai che ce la fai
ma che tipo ma cos'è sta roba
una
quindi cosa vuol dire che schifo frate
volo dai solo perché sono nero mimì
maltratti maledetto razzista
[Musica]
tu sei in una chat giornale continua il
presidio set biohazard bene ma voi
volete dirmi che io avevo una pistola e
non ho sparato niente un cazzo di
proiettile a cosa è servito trovare la
pistola quei progetti un cazzo
bene fantastico ragazzi miei come al
solito quando conclude i video con il
guar siamo in queste condizioni per e
sono contento hanno giocato un gioco
bello e all'euro quindi ragazzoni spero
che vide vi sia piaciuto con la seduta
mi è piaciuto al momento è un mi piace
anche ai vari social che come
individuata nella descrizione sai dove
ti vi siete lì ci vediamo nel prossimo
video magari faccio anche la versione
completa fatemi sapere se la volete io
sono solo che contento
beh ragazzi